you asked I watched we have a new slate
of woke commercials this time the evils
of the patriarchy I will guess the
products I will get it right even though
I don't know a lot about feminism
because I am a man as a man you know I
love delicious red meat
this video is sponsored by good ranchers
more from good ranchers in a moment
first though let's get to the first
world commercial
who's my pretty girl
he dresses
Sammy sweetie don't get your dress dirty
maybe like clothing of some sort broadly
because that's that's the product that's
the most forward here let's put him down
oh maybe not though because it's like
don't don't mess up your pretty dress
girl and that's like bad
product has gotten out of control
[Music]
whoa and careful with that why don't you
hand that to your brother
[Applause]
like a like an education company
brilliant too
her love of Science and Technology and
Inspire her to change the Verizon okay
all right I was never gonna get that can
you hear me now
I also love
it says 66 of girls who are in what
fourth grade they say that they like
science and math but then a much lower
percentage actually major in science and
math and college might it have something
to do with the fact that college level
math and science is a lot harder than
fourth grade math and science is math
related to science
not to suggest that perhaps these are
not things that we can compare no
probably not no it's probably just
because your dad was mean to you yeah
that's what it was okay keep going what
do I tell my daughter
do I tell her that her grandpa's worth
more than her grandma
ramp is worth more than they don't have
a shared bank account that her dad is
worth more than her mom
[Music]
guys just get a shared checking account
you normal do I tell her that despite
her education her drive her skills her
intelligence
she will automatically be valued as less
than every man she ever meets
by whom
are you
I don't I have no idea what the hell it
was like Oreos Procter and Gamble or
maybe it's always Proctor and Gamble one
I don't know I'll be able to tell her
something different
Audi howdy
it's funny because the the setup to the
commercial reveals just how perverse the
the feministry of the world is what am I
supposed to tell her that women are
worth so much less than men bro where
did you hear that where did you get that
idea for you didn't get that idea from
me I don't think women are worth less
than men I'm as conservative as they get
I'm just saying it's the popular view
that women are just absolute trash
they're like the dirt under my feet
maybe that's your view man that ain't my
view I know that's not the conservative
view well by the standards of our modern
culture women don't have as many jobs
and they don't get paid as much in
certain Fields don't you think that you
might be the one perhaps devaluing women
by suggesting that all of the uniquely
feminine virtues and abilities are are
worthless what am I supposed to tell my
son my son won't ever be able to get
pregnant I can't have a baby am I
supposed to tell my son he's worth less
than a girl no but it's pretty amazing
to get pregnant that's to actually
create and nurture life in your womb
that's a that's a pretty incredible
thing you know men are not worth less
than women because they can't do that
and women are not worth less than men
because their spatial reasoning is maybe
a little bit different is math related
to science so they tell me I don't know
I'm just telling you what I read on the
internet they're not in competition with
each other at least they're not supposed
to be they are complementary to one
another the the yin to the others Yang
okay it's really it's just feminism that
puts them in competition with one
another and they say Okay women the only
thing that matters is or all of the
masculine virtues and the things that
men typically are better at running
races and I don't know working in an
office or something then when women
don't quite stack up or they don't work
as many hours or they don't run as fast
or they can't compete against the men in
sports then they say well what are women
supposed to be less no in a world in
which you only value things that men
tend to do better than than women are
going to have a tougher time but we
didn't do that it's the libs that did
that speaking of manly things I love
eating red meat and I like cooking for
my family sometimes even too I love
spending the holidays with my family one
of the ways that I like to do that is
with delicious made from good ranchers
is a special gift to our listeners this
holiday season good ranchers is giving
away two Black Angus New York strip
steaks free with your order these are
two 12-ounce Steakhouse quality cuts a
70 value for free you do not want to
miss this offer
I'll tell you why Black Angus tastes
better and is more tender than any other
beef black angus meat is marbled in such
a way that the fat is distributed thinly
and evenly this marbling gives it a
consistent flavor that you don't get
with other meats plus the Black Angus
from good ranchers is hand cut and
trimmed by expert butchers so you know
every piece is going to be Exquisite
while grocery store meat prices are on
the rise good ranchers is dedicated to
helping you save as much as possible if
you subscribe to good ranchers today you
can lock in your price and avoid those
insanely high prices at the grocery
store and get some free meat while
you're at it go to goodranchors.com
Knowles use code Knowles at checkout for
this special offer that's
goodranchers.com Knowles for two Black
Angus New York strip steaks free with
your order good ranchers American Meat
delivered okay let's go on with the what
commercials
one inventor is Benjamin Franklin
Leonardo da Vinci Thomas Edison
Alexander Bell always the point that
they don't name any female inventors
because statistically all the inventors
of things have been men rather it's kind
of a tough one it is a tough one yeah
um in school it's a product I don't know
mail inventor I just realized
it's like radiation like uh Marie Curie
discovered
[Music]
brake pads
to know that there were women hold on
hold on you're telling me a woman
invented Rockets I don't think I believe
in something and make maybe like a
change but I don't know what the product
is cool
[Applause]
Frederick gamble Microsoft oh that was
rough I didn't have a clue on any of
those and it was unfortunately it wasn't
Procter and Gamble so I couldn't even
it's kind of how I felt about the
Republicans in the 2022 midterms you
know I went in with much higher hopes
than we ended up getting I gave I gave a
kind of a fetterman I support fracking
and I stand and I do support fracking
okay it was the Federman performance of
what commercials we'll try again next
time send in your what commercials
we'll see
[Music]